on ne trouve pas une planche tout fait
comme ça dans le commerce avant d'avoir
eu obtenir une planche on sélectionne
notre voie et on l'assembl ée et on la
colle eli s'installe est un peu comme
obélix l'ébénisterie elle est tombée
dedans quand elle était petite
à 39 ans est plaisir waes travaille le
bois depuis 16 ans ollier dans les
copeaux j'ai grandi au milieu des
meubles et des dés dans l'atelier de mon
papa j'avais toujours voir si je pouvais
pas d un petit coup de main donc les
odeurs le bois
mon papa était aussi antiquaires donc il
y avait toujours des meubles qui
rentrait qui repartaient qui était monté
et démonté
donc c'est vrai que c'était familier
après une formation d'aménagement
d'intérieur en belgique il y suit un crp
d'ébénisterie son activité principale la
commande de particuliers dans mon
ébénisterie outre la restauration de
mobilier je réalise des meubles sur
mesure et je réalise des créations aussi
donc
des meubles que j'ai envie de dessiner
de réaliser ainsi que des objets
décoratifs en bois
donc soit en tournage sur bois soie de
pareilles les petits meubles petits
objets le fait de produire des choses à
la main c'est un gage de qualité parce
que en fait en tout cas chez moi c'est
pas à part des petites séries c'est pas
de la production de masse donc moi j'ai
à coeur de choisir de bien choisir mon
bois le veinage du bois les assemblages
la façon de le faire duchesne de
l'érable sycomore du merisier eli
s'installe se fournit principalement
dans les pays où les forêts sont
durablement gérées un savoir faire
qu'elle partagea son tour je forme
actuellement un jeune homme qui est avec
moi pour la quatrième année et j
accueille régulièrement des stagiaires
donc ils sont soit en école de
menuiserie soit en école d'ébénisterie
et puis aussi ponctuellement des
des gens qui sont éventuellement en
reconversion professionnelle dont qui
s'interroge sur le fait de travailler
dans moi il y a 6 ans élise installe son
atelier à plaisir mobilier éléments de
décoration ou jouets pour enfants une
activité qui n'a pas fini de tourner